[Music]
[Music]
oh what a lad and boy have i got a treat
for you with this one today's guest has
had what seems like one of the longest
careers ever he started way back in 2003
with the wellington lions before a call
up with the hurricanes came not long
after that he then moved up to north
harbor in the blues for a season before
heading over to the uk where he's widely
regarded as one of the greatest kiwi
imports ever
this is where we saw him dominate for
teams including the newcastle falcons
leinster and of course the warps and
he's won all sorts of accolades along
the way but that doesn't count for much
unless you are a lad and he is one of
the greatest lads around it is the great
jimmy goberth welcome mate
hey what an intro uh yeah happy to be on
mate seen a lot of these podcasts
they're good fun so happy to
be along
mate what a career unbelievable scenes i
remember watching you as a young fellow
as a big hurricanes fan watching you on
the telly and to see that you're still
going and still going so strong
incredible achievement
yeah i've been uh been fortunate uh to
to still be able to play this game
especially uh playing in
what is probably the hardest league in
the world it's relentless the
premiership um so yeah to still be
playing
um it's in the age of 20 it's uh going
alright mate
yeah right like you say like the
competition over there is so hard and a
lot of guys say they sort of shorten
their career when they go over there but
mate you've extended you're somehow
playing week in and week out massive
amounts of games um unreal
yeah it's been
you know obviously
and moving from from 10 to playing a lot
at 12 these days as well which yeah it
does not do the body any good mate it's
just tackling hitting rocks
chasing kicks
so it's definitely going to take a few
years off me but uh yeah just fortunate
to um
you know i suppose my body's been pretty
good for me uh right throughout my
career and to be able to still play at
the highest level is um you know i just
don't want to go to a day job so i'm
hanging in there until the wheels fall
off all right that's it stay on it
because you're coming up to 39 aren't
you so i think only ben may is the only
one i've had on who's playing and is a
little bit older than you so that's
unreal achievement but um you mentioned
your body feeling pretty good have you
ever had have you got any niggles or
you're still feeling like as fresh as
you were when you were 24
yeah no i've got no niggles at the
moment um i've only really had
uh
three sort of well one major injury
that's when i've done my uh acl back in
what 2018
yeah that was sort of my first ever
proper sort of beyond sort of three
months 12 weeks uh injury and
that was a bit of an experience to go
through
that sort of nine months of playing and
then managed to get back early and first
game out there uh playing saracens try
and put a big hit in um first tackle
break my thumb
and keep going play the rest of the game
because there's no way i was coming off
so it's like broken and dislocated so
i'm running around the pitch trying to
like put it back in after every tackle
because you know you've been out for
nine months man you do not want to come
off because everyone will be like oh
he's bugging again
and then that was lucky i just about
finished pre-season and then sort of get
back in and first game back in
pre-season against uh saracens again
done my ac so i had three in a row but
other than that i've been pretty uh
pretty good for my career
is there any secret to having that and
being so um durable um i don't know mate
it's probably my my days of on the farm
just drinking milk straight out of the
cow's other uh
it must have had some goodness in there
you know
god knows what we're putting in our body
off the farm but yeah i think just
having that having a balanced life um
you know surfing's been a big passion of
mine right for as a young kid so i think
that's probably brought
real good stability to my joints
especially sort of my upper body with
paddling and stuff like that so
who knows i think it's probably
got to just do something with it because
you see a lot of the young kids now and
they just break all the time yes but i
think
we play a lot of rugby and
especially up here a lot of young kids
don't play as much as we would back home
because of the squad sizes and and
different sort of uh competitions so you
know durability helps by just planing
loads and loads of rugby
mate surfing and milk straight from the
teeth love that all the kids will be
doing that
and i read an article that you'd retired
from wasps not that long ago i thought
this was going to be the big
announcement jimmy goff is going to
retire from rugby but you haven't is it
true that you've signed with let's start
or is this nothing yet
it's i have signed for another club but
it's not official
but i've signed um yeah i've signed a
one plus one deal so if i go through the
two i'll be still playing
when i'm finishing on 41 wow
which would be pretty cool
yeah
so what what brought about the move like
obviously you're a wasp legend you
played
plenty of games for wasps everyone loves
you there and what what brought about
the move here um look it was obviously i
was off contract uh
coming into the season and obviously
people knew
and then teams just started showing a
bit of interest and
it's really weird over here at the
moment because all the um salary caps
are dropping in in size yeah so they've
been cut i don't know the exact figures
but it might have been like seven and a
half million per team last season now
it's down to like five and a half
uh so a lot of teams are trying to deal
with you know trying to bring all this
squad together with certain amounts of
money and
yeah i just i just went to us because i
had an offer on the table and i just
went to them and told them
i had an offer on the table and um you
know the balls in your court but they
weren't able to do anything when this
other team wanted to move pretty quickly
so
at 38 years old i wasn't going to hang
around
i had an opportunity so i took it
how good is that the offers are just
rolling in at 38 years old you're on
fire
yeah it's not too bad
was it hard to leave that club though
wasps
yeah it will be obviously i've played
here for seven seasons now seven years
um
i think uh you know i've got i'm on 149
games so i've got one more for a big 150
and
um
you know
done a shitload and been been in two
finals with them and done you know i've
seen the team progress
um
pretty pretty quickly throughout the
years and being a part of that so of
course it's always hard when you leave a
club that you've put so much into
um but hopefully i've left it um
with a few good memories and as long as
people sort of know i've contributed as
much as i can while i'm here then you
know i'll leave with happy thoughts
memories
no doubt and was there ever a thought of
you coming back to new zealand and
giving it one more crack here that
question came in so much from many
taranaki fans coastal fans wellington
line fans hurricane fans they all want
to see you back here at some point as
was that ever that ever that ever
crossed your mind uh yeah a little um
you know my agents did ask me if i
wanted to come home and um yeah it
wasn't my thoughts uh to to sort of come
and try it black out and and see how it
goes and
yeah it's just one of those things that
uh
you know this offer came in pretty
quickly so i didn't really have time to
sort of look into to too much and
who knows i might come back as a 40 year
old and still try and try and mix it
with the young kids and um you know i've
been told by a lot to the coastal lads
back at home i have to save a couple
games in the legs
to roll on the green and white mate and
down down on the coast and
um you know if i
it'd be cool man if i could come back
and still be able to play and then like
even play for the nike would be unreal
but yeah we'll see we'll see what
happens uh when i finish up here
right that would be unreal to see you
back here 41 years old maybe ben mate at
prop 42 years old you guys just locking
it down from taramaki
that'd be unreal mate
but if you might have to only train but
two days a week but it will be right
right they'll let you away with it
surely easy but while we're at um while
we're on new zealand um i know you are a
proud taranaki man so pretty keen to
hear what it was like for you growing up
there
yeah awesome mate obviously down this uh
the small little town of piharma just
outside of open acci
right on the beach
so you know dairy farm so we just had
the had the beach right there the farm
so just always just outdoors cruising
around
fishing kneeling surfing you know you
name it we did it
and then obviously went up to new
plymouth boys
boarding school up there for five years
created uh some awesome memories up
there had some great mates
you know the rugby went up there for the
rugby really just to try and try and see
how far i could go and
uh managed to sort of kick on from there
from the nike and
uh you know had the opportunity to
to go down to wellington straight out of
uh out of school which was you know
obviously the stepping stone to my
career but yeah the childhood just
coming up mate it's it's one of those
ones now i look back and i'm with my
kids um
yeah it's something we'll probably look
at because it is special man it's uh
it's such a special place to grow up
so you mentioned you moved to new
plymouth boys for rugby when did you
think that rugby was potentially a
pathway for you
um i think all little all uh kiwis just
have have that uh dream don't they of
becoming a professional rugby player
becoming an all black and
i think
i was fortunate enough like just during
primary school all my like my best mates
were sort of a year older than me so
they all went off to high school so and
i was still at primary school but i
would go and play for their high school
team uh open accu high i'd go and play
for them and um i sort of
you know sort of
got told i sort of had
i was not too bad at rugby so you know
the best next thing is you know my whole
my whole family uh go to went to frances
douglas but then
they weren't that great at rugby and and
new plymouth boys were so
i thought that was the best next step to
to try and uh make something out of it
to put myself in a good school and and
go from there
and i've got one of the best grounds
ever in rugby i reckon one of the
coolest grounds to play at what was it
like playing at the galley mate it's
unreal eh it's uh
you know you have 1200 boys watching you
on one side doing the haka and yeah you
know all the other family friends and
that on the other and
you just don't get that kind of
atmosphere and um you know anywhere
really and to have it in school uh was a
such a privilege
and you know some of those those college
matches you play and
mate like the boys are like crying and
stuff before games like you just like
they get so amped up and it means so
much and we used to um like just before
you run down the gully there's a bell
tower and
we used to all get up there and huddle
up and say you know who are we boys high
and just rock it up and get louder and
louder and then sprint down the hill and
all the borders would be lined up doing
the hakka so you go through one haka
then you do your haka then the school's
doing a haka it's just mental it's uh i
try and tell people over here like what
school rugby is like and they just they
don't understand it mate like
it's special
hey that is such a pumper did you ever
find it hard getting yourself up not
playing at the galley
it was different it was definitely
different um especially some of the
early days like we
because some of the other schools around
us weren't that great um and sort of so
we played uh we ended up playing senior
thirds and and the tarantula rugby comp
and like senior thirds man
you know it's like
all the sort of ex uh
senior first guys like all the guys like
35 30 just there for a drink and no [ __ ]
the first first 20 minutes is the
hardest game of rugby you'll ever play
they just out there and kick the [ __ ]
out of here because you're like you're
little kids like they'll just kick the
[ __ ] out here and then
after 30 minutes they're so tired you
just run around them and just score all
the tries but uh that was um it was
always dawns he made like turning up to
some grounds
and uh
and sort of seeing all these guys
massive old guys and having a beer
before they even some of them even
before they play like it was pretty
pretty daunting but
uh there was some fun times man
it's good times and then you mentioned
your move down to wellington was there
ever an opportunity for you to stay with
taranaki was that ever the goal or did
this wellington opportunity just come
out of nowhere
um yeah it was obviously growing up i
always wanted to play for the nike went
to watch them all the time
in my last year of school
they did talk about trying to get me
into the team that year
um to play but there was a bit of
like nah he's too young um sort of thing
going on so
um which i was mad keen for obviously um
to play in the npc and still at school
but yeah they thought i was a bit too
young so i just stayed playing high
school rugby and
yeah and then obviously did pretty well
at um
with the hurricane schools in new
zealand schools and and wellington came
pretty quickly and and said you know
look come join our academy and when
when the wellington team had you know
the superstars they had i thought wow
it's a great opportunity for me to go
and learn
from um and yeah it worked out pretty
well
yeah for sure and then what was it like
going into that environment oh you
mentioned that you got the guys like
cullen and all these legends of the game
you're rocking up there as a 19 20 year
old
having to boss these guys around
it was nuts mate like um in my last year
of school like we were
like in the boarding school so i was a i
was a head prefect of one of the one of
the uh sort of boarding schools and
every year at the start of school you
bring the young kids in like the third
formers and sort of just give them
orientation like like get them used to
the place before the school starts and
before the borders come back in i
remember we're down sort of towards okra
beach and just for an afternoon and the
kids were young kids were out on the
beach playing and a few of us sitting in
the van listening to new zealand sevens
playing at wellington yeah i think kelly
was playing lomi was playing
a few of these guys were all playing and
we're just like i mean and then at the
end of that year the next year i'm
walking to the changing room and there
they all are like just to sit in there i
was just like oh my god this is nuts um
you know you had
jonah there with this big skyline uh car
this massive sound system and i was just
like
turn up my little uh ford telstar like
thinking what's going on
but
they were they were they were awesome um
obviously dave holwell and and spicy
were there and and they sort of looked
after us young guys and um yeah it sort
of showed us the ropes and helped us
help help me personally learn so much
yeah because it looked like a pretty
intimidating backline to be in control
of and to be trying to boss around but
you you seem to love it
yeah it was awesome like obviously you
know i think it was a few weeks in and
and tana came up to me and just said
look mate you're a 10.
just boss us around um and so when you
get the the okay from
the legend um then
you know you sort of relax and you get a
bit of confidence and and then sort of
went on from there so and that's
obviously 10 you have to you have to be
bossing the boys around and be pretty
vocal
and so that was pretty cool
for a guy like to give me a bit of
advice and
sort of cracked on and really enjoyed
him with some of those guys
and absolutely killed it and one story i
do want to know about is a bus trip back
from waikato apparently this is one of
the greats
oh [ __ ] so
we always used to obviously fly to all
the games and it was pretty early on 03.
uh we were we played in waikato had a
good win and obviously it's a there's
quite a few of us new guys um then so
like myself pity weapo
uh numerity ladder all these guys were
sort of first year so obviously you have
a have an initiation have a bit of a a
jug skull and go out have an awesome
night and we end up having an awesome
night got absolute [ __ ] shit-faced
um
and then the
we were leaving pretty early in the
morning i think it was like that flight
was pretty early
and i just remembered feeling i'm a bit
like i'm pretty ropey like um but i was
just hanging in there so we got through
the flight swedes and we'd always park
our cars down at the stadium and then
get shuttles from the stadium down to um
from the airport down the stadium
and i don't know how i manage it but i
got myself into the shuttle with it was
uh
in the front row i think it was spicy me
um
dave holwell cully
i think tana was in there i even think
john plum tree and bloody um chris
boydrin they're the coaches
and this you know the ride from airport
to the stadium is it's not that far yeah
and i remember just like
you know when you start getting the
sweats
outside
just like hanging in there i remember i
think spicy might have turned to me and
goes mate you're right and i was like
just obviously i'm young as i'm just
like yep yep
and we got down i think it was um
maybe taranaki street and then the
corner of like dixon street like pretty
much you know like with les mills at
like literally in the middle of town on
an early sunday morning it must have
been about 11 o'clock sunday morning
and the lights went red and i remember
just going nah [ __ ] i'm dust
opening the door just like going over
top of i think it might have been cully
and just power chucking over
on the [ __ ] ground
and like oh like the legends are in the
group and just shut the door and just
sat there like that
i was [ __ ] myself i thought i was
going to get sacked because the coaches
are in there
everyone's in there and i was just like
what have you just done
and it was uh obviously spike jason's
wife's pretty funny dude he was cracking
up
and but i just don't really know what
happened uh other than that because i
just went into shut down i was just head
down didn't say a thing i was just like
i was so so embarrassed
so embarrassed
you just blanked out never spoke about
it again
no i was like that that can't be
happening like
it's one of my first games and like
initiations i was like
[ __ ] never again like
oh that's so good
and then your call up to the hurricanes
came not long after that how did you
find that whole experience
yeah that was awesome i obviously played
2003 2004
uh for the for the lions and never
started the game
just always came off the bench just
which i reckon was awesome like i just
learned so much by doing that yeah um
then got the call up to o5 uh when dave
holdwell went off to i went to leinster
actually i think so ricky flutie was
there
he was going to be number one uh for the
canes i was obviously going to back him
up and then pre-season flutes got
injured uh
i can't remember what he'd done but he
was out for a bit
so colin cooper is like look you're
starting first game
you know uh at the ballymore playing the
reds
um and it was it was it was nuts mate
and it was it was a real tough week for
me as well because my grandad
bernie fleming was loads of the coastal
people will know passed away and it was
just massive big influence in sort of my
life and um
and so i was a bit like oh [ __ ] you know
i've had this opportunity do i go home
and then it was pretty cool my nana rang
me up and said there's absolutely no way
you're coming home like you're playing
um
and then from there i just just
really just uh i had a blinding start to
be honest like it was uh it was pretty
surreal the way i started my my super
career and
just never looked back and and held on
to that jersey the the whole year
were you confident going into that first
game or was it only after that game
where you really grew your confidence
um i think i was i was confident i was
obviously as a confident young kid um
and to have the likes of tana uh um you
know around me and and his leadership
just made it so much easier um for me
just to do my job and you know i had the
bat row you know you you look at the
back you had jerry collins and rodney
suialo chris marzoi guys like that
like i could offload anything around
them so yeah i didn't have to worry too
much and i love the fence like i'd
always get stuck in and and and rip in
and that sort of part so
they gave me the confidence just to go
out and play my game and
you know i was hung this little [ __ ] and
took heaps of heaps of line breaks
scored heaps of tries and had a hell of
a year
what made tana's leadership so special
he just knew what to say
and when to say it and it was always
what he said was just the right thing um
and he he didn't speak overly to like
too much
but
it was just times like he just knew the
group of players around him so these
times during training when you know
things weren't going right and just
looks at the coaches and and sort of
says look
stop banging banging a drum here like
cut it or you know we need to do x y and
zed and um he just led by example
and and just sort of always gave ev as i
said before gave everyone around them
confidence to to play their game because
you knew he was going to be on on fire
himself
so he
he was an outstanding leader and i think
herman and rodney suialo was
also just an outstanding leader
within that group
and they sort of combined really really
well together and especially for us
young guys it was two two brilliant guys
to to follow
legends of the game eh and then one
thing that everyone in new zealand knows
you for is wearing the gloves you've
still got the reputation as a glove
wearer here in new zealand going from
the questions
what made you decide to wear the gloves
and where have they gone
oh mate the gloves the boys still over
here asked me to bring them back they
want me to bring them back mate
i don't know i think it just it was an
in thing wasn't it it just started
coming in i think george smith used them
um
you know over in australia and then the
few boys just started using them and it
was like obviously you play in the rain
and uh
you know just helped with a little bit
of grip and so i thought oh you know why
not um give him a crack and they sort of
stayed around for a while and
uh you know then i seen
you know all the boys over here talk
about oh i still play rugby 08 and
you've got this goadie and these you've
got the gloves on and
all these things and
so it's pretty funny um yeah pretty
funny way to uh to be known by the glove
man
when did you decide to cancel i don't
think i can bring the bat
why did you can them
i don't know actually i honestly i don't
know why um i can them if
um maybe i was getting a bit too much
[ __ ] for them i'm not too sure so um
yeah but they sort of i don't know when
i left them either so
it might have been around so i don't i
might have only had them for a year or
so i definitely had them in o5
but 06 i don't think i had too much of
them so it might just be a sort of the
old one one hit wonder yeah and you just
got tired with this reputation of
playing the glove where your whole life
i know mate
that limit
yeah and then one moment that stands out
from your hurricane's career was that
fog final um down there in christchurch
against the crusaders what do you
remember about that one
yeah look obviously we had a pretty
awesome semi-final and yeah i was pretty
lucky to come on and and get the old
match winning penalty
um to get to the final and then when
we're down there it was like just before
like that whole week man we were feeling
really really confident
like we really knew our game we knew how
we wanted to play
even the warm-up started to warm up
awesome went back inside came back out
and we were like what the hell is going
on here like you couldn't see [ __ ] yeah
and it just put a real dampener on the
whole game
and you know just from the start like
fans were leaving to try and watch it at
home when it was worse on tv yeah
you know you had commentators running up
and down the sidelines like commentating
on the game it was carnage mate
and yeah it's still a really tight game
um and obviously that one try from casey
lalala
sort of just broke it open but yeah we
we honestly really believe that was our
time um
but then obviously you give crusaders a
shot and and they take it
so
obviously it'll be it's a final you'll
never forget
but to come so close as an opportunity
to try and win it um yeah it's pretty
gutting
and how was it for a 10 playing in a
game where you could hardly see you
obviously couldn't couldn't see the
backfield or anything like that when
you're kicking the game control the game
management must have been tough
mate high balls were crazy um and
there's even some there's some clips
i've seen of
amish getting a few
shots at goal and you can you can barely
see the post like it was just
it was just out of like i've never
experienced like anything ever yeah
yet to really focus on what you're doing
and
it sort of it was two good teams going
to head to head to head but it did ruin
the game a bit because
you know there was a lot of kicking
because
you were trying to test the other team
because they couldn't you know just see
if they can see the ball and try and get
the mistake and
um
so i think if the fog wasn't there i
think i still believe it would have been
one hell of a final like a real really
really good final but yeah in saying
that it was a different type of final
and
um
the people that got to see a little bit
probably uh agreed that it was a good
game of footy
for sure so then what brought about the
move
up to auckland and the blues and north
harbour so you're playing well for the
canes you've got into a final and why
the move
um well i just wanted something a little
different um you know when you're with
the wellington and the hurricanes you
are at the same place the whole time
yeah so i thought it's trying something
different went up to north harbour
really enjoyed myself like we played
some played some good footy and and
managed to get in the blues uh enjoyed
that as well different environment uh
different players
um and
sort of the end of that year
it's sort of an opportunity just came up
to to have a look overseas and
and then sort of went on from there
had you had any feedback from the all
black coaches throughout any of this
time
there was a little bit every now and
then um you know there was times i met
uh a few of them and and went into um
you know things like that but yeah there
was there was loads of us around that
sort of time myself um
obviously dc was still playing mertz was
still playing when we were there and
sure um you know stevie donald and luke
mcallister nick evans was still there
for a bit so there was loads and loads
of guys like we know i think was o5 we
all had the all black trial
and sort of made the juniors off the
back of that and
um so it was i sort of knew i was sort
of in in and around it but you know it
was just you never know until you see to
hear your name and you still got to play
well and um you know i i know i had a
few inconsistent games around sort of
0607
um
and that was just learning and you know
so
it made me a better player in the long
run but um unfortunately um
yeah i looked to go overseas before i
could see what happens
yeah so that's a big question that
everyone wants to know around you is why
that move so young so you're only what
25 which was pretty young
these days those days to be moving
overseas and i'm heading over to the uk
so what was the big
deciding factor to head over there
um well i just had my daughter was only
like nine months so had a young family
and you know it was sort of that sort of
bat log and the all blacks was still
pretty solid um you know you knew dc
wasn't going anywhere for a long time uh
stevie donald was getting a little bit
of a looking
at that stage um so i just thought
why not uh why not have an opportunity
to to go over and experience a different
side of the world and you know if it's
just go over for a couple years and then
come back and and get that experience
and then come back and
that was sort of sort of the first plan
and but here i'm still sitting here
playing so it didn't uh didn't eventuate
to come back to new zealand but
yeah it was an
opportunity to to go over and sort of
just see the different side of the world
and
and
uh explore
did you think your style of footy would
suit the uk style or was that just
purely coincidence that that happened
i didn't really know to be honest um
obviously i was lucky because i had a
couple mates over here
in newcastle playing so obviously carl
heyman was here tana tupelotu which i
played with that hurricanes and lions
was here
so i got to talk to them a lot and and
they sort of explained what it was like
and
when i was going there i was like well
that's probably not my style but
that's what i wanted i wanted the
challenge and i wanted to see if i can
broaden my game because you know i did
have um thoughts about coming back to
new zealand so i was like what's what
you know going broader my whole game and
and hopefully i can come back a better
player and a better person to push and
but got over there and found out pretty
quickly i had to adapt my game uh pretty
smart
which you did and you did it quicker
than most i mean a lot of guys who go
over there sort of it takes two or three
years for them to sort of get used to
the style over there in the complete
different way they manage their games
especially as a 10 but mate you seem to
make a seamless transition and
right from the get-go you were kicking
goals and winning games
i was very lucky i had carl heyman in
the front row that was uh just giving me
all the penalties and i was just kicking
the points that was uh that was how it
was working but um
yeah it was
it was very much uh a sort of territory
game i had to really sort of um learn it
was all about keeping keeping the ball
in front of your forwards and keeping
the pressure on them you know there was
time i remember times there was like
uh a scrum like you know
just like probably 30 meters into our
own half like you know just on the 40
like yeah and i'd look over me and tarni
would be like let's go and all all the
other boys are looking at us like what
do you mean let's go like kick it in the
corner
and we're like
it was a bit of a learning curve because
i was always running i i love running
with the ball
yeah um so there was a few occasions
where i'd just take off and
and and run but obviously the defenses
were not expecting that either either so
it sort of worked on my favor a little
bit and obviously tane was uh always on
my back he knew
what was up
um but yeah we you had to adapt your
game pretty pretty quickly um and
fortunately the whole game's changed now
over here which was pretty cool
and you were replacing johnny wilkinson
is that right was there any pressure
extra pressure around that
yeah it was it was pretty crazy because
obviously everyone knew johnny wilkinson
um you know world cup world cup winner
uh with the famous drop goal and play
for newcastle for for you know years so
he was like the favorite son of
newcastle so there was a little bit of
pressure um and i remember my first game
didn't go like well i played a right but
i missed quite a few kicks
um we played away and the weirdest one i
probably missed because you know what
it's like over here you go for a shot at
goal and it's definitely silent
like no one speaks
and i remember my first few games i'm
like looking around going what is going
on like make some noise man like you go
to wakarosa stadium i remember possum in
the cherry picker working with his
chainsaw like
like with the cowbells like that's what
i was used to
and now i was over there just definitely
silent so after that first game it was a
bit like oh he's never going to be able
to replace him but
fortunately i got
used to it pretty quickly and
made up made amends for those couple
early misses
yeah and ended up being the top point
scorer was it that yeah
yeah i fortunately got that uh well a
couple years in a row and as i say it
was on the back of uh
some pretty good work from uh from carl
and the and the boys up front to be
honest um we're we weren't scoring a
hell of a lot of tries we were just uh
kicking threes kicking threes right and
center with um you know we we're sort of
low low table uh team you know i think
the highest i ever
my first year i think we finished like
eighth or something like that then it
was always just battling for relegation
like finishing 11th 11th
so i had to take the points to be honest
yeah and how do you find the relegation
battles i know it's gone now but and
what was it like as a player having to
fight for your life
for a lot of your seasons
mate
it's tough eh it's really tough like
you know people are fighting for
contracts it's not just uh you know
because obviously you drop down to the
to the championship and it's um you know
some guys get let go and i i'll never
forget one year we're playing um bath
away
and worcester were playing
i can't remember who they were playing
but they were playing at their place so
it was a battle between us and worcester
to see who stays up
and
our game for summer or their game for
some reason because everyone plays on
the last day everyone plays three
o'clock saturday every game same time so
everyone knows what's going on
and we played bath and our game had
finished and everyone and we lost and
i think we might have been like a
if worcester at one
um
would go down by a point or something
like that
and everyone's like the worcester games
not finished we're like what do you mean
it's like there's an injury or something
delay and and the hammering on the line
like they're picking going on the line
to win the game
and it was surreal mate like we were all
in a huddle
on the the wreck at bar
and there were guys crying they're guys
that couldn't listen like the the coach
was in there with um
the phone like listening to the to the
commentary and boys are like have i got
a job next year like are we in the
championship are we in the premiership
and uh all we remember is they it was
like they're over they're over oh no
wait the ball's been stripped and like
we just went
like it was crazy mate we just went mean
to him and managed to uh manage to stay
up by the skin of our teeth but
i look i don't wish that on any
obviously the fans love it like the
drama is nuts mate
but as a player man i don't wish that
upon anybody it's pretty tough to take
yeah 100 so you're glad that they've
scrapped it
uh
in a way yeah
it's definitely opening the game up over
here
a lot of teams are really playing
and
people say well there's some teams that
haven't got much to play for but there's
still a lot because obviously we've got
european rugby as well so you've got to
finish i think they changed it now so
you've got to finish on top eight
to make it through to europe so that's a
big sort of ploy as well to keep the
teams uh interested but we are seeing
some young kids come through we're
seeing a lot more tries high scoring
games so i think it's helping in the
style of game for sure but i think every
fan just wants that drama
for sure yeah as a fan i think the
relegation is obviously awesome but as a
player
one who experienced it as well
it's not a nice feeling having to go
down to the championship did you never
played in the championship did you
or did ya
mate
2000 yeah uh my last year of the falcons
before i went to lancaster oh
yeah that was another yeah another crazy
one
oh mate it's uh
you go to some you go to it's like
playing club rugby yeah like you go to
some dark places like we played
it was the year that leeds um leeds's
pitch at headingley was infested with
some kind of
i don't know bug so they couldn't play
there
so we played otley now otley a lot of uh
older people will know otley is like
famous like the all blacks played there
and god knows how long ago and i think
they got beat
um on this field anyway but we were
playing otley and playing leads and the
weather was all right like it wasn't too
bad we kicked off literally score like
we're winning every game by 50
50 points
um
and we kick off score a try it's like
sweet and then the heavens opened and no
[ __ ] within 30 minutes you couldn't tell
who was who
and there was one stage when one of our
guys tackled our own player
around the rock because he didn't know
who was who like it was proper like just
old school rugby and i think we ended up
winning
uh like two points it might have been
like ten ten nine or something it was
nuts
we're all having like photos and stuff
after the game because we just thought
it was hilarious like but yeah you go to
some dark places what game was harder
that one or the fog final
ah that one for sure mate
you couldn't run it was like playing on
a potato potato field man you couldn't
run you couldn't do anything
so you got them you got them promoted
again and is this when you decided to
fill in for another legend johnny sexton
over at leinster
yeah mate it was um
yeah joe schmidt was was obviously the
coach of leinster and we caught up the
olympics were on um
in london and we caught up because one
of his family members was i think he was
the golf keeper of the all whites and he
they were playing the newcastle against
brazil so we caught up and he was like
look you know
what are you doing and uh next year and
all i said well look i've got out
clauses in my contract but you know i'm
just happy to to see what happens and
he's like well you know if i go anywhere
or anything happens i'll be keen to take
you with me
and then get a phone call again johnny
sexton's leaving to orisi metro uh would
you be interested come over and i was
like what so the european champions yup
see ya sign that like gone uh i was i
was like you know you don't you don't
turn uh turn that down
and then it was like
three weeks later he rang me and goes
yeah um
i've i'm not going to be your coach
because i've just signed for ireland i'm
going to be the irish head coach but
don't worry don't worry the new coach is
coming in wants you anyway so
fortunately it's uh matt o'connor came
in and
he still wanted me so i was a bit
sketchy there for a while but
yeah that was awesome mate over at
leinster uh what an outfit yeah the
european multiple multiple european
champions for a reason um just
a great environment to be
involved with and dublin's one hell of a
city
so what makes the environment so good
um just their professionalism and
they're all winners uh they're all
striving to win and and they know how to
win
and you know it's sort of the the young
stock coming through it's probably
it's literally probably the same as new
zealand the young stock coming through
is
um just really really good they come
through some very big schools over there
um
and and just sort of it's like this
conveyor belt and they just go through
and
it seems all the decent players went to
leinster um and then sort of lengths
from monster with the two big teams and
so
yeah they just always knew how to win
and
you know my first year we won the pro 14
which is pretty cool
and how did all the cultures compare
from the hurricanes blues
um
newcastle to lancer how do they all
how they how are they all different
like obviously every different cult
every culture is different um
but
sort of
the majority is everyone loves rugby so
that will never change wherever you go
obviously new zealand's uh really about
family um and being tight together as a
brotherhood and um you know it's it's
you do a lot together off the field
uh newcastle was pretty tight we had a
group of foreigners
um you know loads of kiwis to be honest
and newcastle was one of our funnest
times like you know if my missus said
you know we're going to live in
newcastle for the rest of our lives you
probably would because it was it was
awesome up there like the rugby was
average but you had the c there so you
still got to get through surfing awesome
night life the people up there are just
like awesome mate they're real good fun
so that we really enjoyed ourselves
there
leenster was a real
uh
work work hard play hard place like um
hardly any any of them then when i was
there had kids
um it was all like not rugby rugby's
first and then when you hit 30 that's
when you decide well i should start
settling down like that was their sort
of motto
so they were devoted to rugby and then
devoted yeah had some pretty good
parties and
uh obviously the nightlife out there so
but that was the changing of times i
think now it's a lot different over
there but yeah that's why probably they
were so determined to win they were so
dedicated
and then wasp is pretty much similar to
to everywhere um all mixed in one um you
got young families and um and then sort
of people sort of scattered all around
the place because obviously we it's a
new sort of club uh yeah it used to be
down in london now we're up sort of
around uh coventry and limits and spa
around this sort of
villages so people sort of scattered all
around but still socialise pretty well
together so
you know any rugby team you walk into it
within two weeks you've got 50 mates so
it's pretty pretty special
pretty special environments to be part
of a professional rugby group
that's the coolest thing about the game
eh so then why the move to the wasp from
leinster the powerhouse of european
rugby
so pretty much i knew i only had two
years because johnny sexton was only
going for two years and then yeah and
then he was coming back and look they
they asked they wanted me to stay but i
was like there's no point like i want to
play and then wasp came to me and i
really like the style that was played uh
it was probably the closest you get to
super rugby um so that that excited me
um to join dai young and his team and uh
so yeah sort of came over and uh just
yeah love loved it uh from day one
and was that when you started to make
more of a move into the midfield playing
more 12
yeah so my first year over here uh when
did i come over so 2015
uh 16th season played all at 10 uh here
it was pretty good season made a couple
semi-finals in europe and and the
premiership
and then the next season uh danny
cipriani side
signed for us
yeah i used to be a wasp um you know it
was like the home homecoming of uh danny
cipriani and
so i i seen it as a challenge i was like
yeah sweet like let's go um we'll try
and i'll try and rival him from the
shirt and then we had a couple injuries
in the midfield and then the coach was
like look do you want to play 12
for the first game and just see how see
how that goes with two playmakers
because you know we really want to spin
the ball wide and i think two playmates
can work and
i was like yeah don't why not let's go
and um
we uh
we actually um created a pretty awesome
partnership and
and and scored some pretty uh outrageous
tries and had had a brilliant season
which uh you know was really really
enjoyable to be a part of and had one
hell of a backline um
and that sort of time and
so it sort of just progressed by because
of opportunities to play 12 and and then
sort of never look back really
what was danny cipriani like to play
outside because obviously my brother
played with him at gloucester and he
rated him as the best ball player he
ever played with i mean he played with
some legends at the crusaders and
the chiefs as well but he rates danny
cipriani as the best out of them all how
was he for you
yeah mate his decision-making on the
ball at the line is second to none um
he
he'll put people in space he'll create
opportunities just by how he sort of
reads the game and his sort of uh
passing techniques
so
he is you know one of if not the best
ball players at the line in in the game
to be honest um it's
puzzling
why you know it's probably different
reasons why he hasn't had more
international caps
uh that we probably won't go into but
his ball play at the line is pretty
phenomenal
but you kept the goalkeeping duties
didn't yeah and
mate something that you have been
consistently good at is kicking your
goals
yeah look i've always loved it um always
always loved goal kicking and and sort
of had a thing for it and so right
throughout my young years to to now it's
uh been a big part of my career and um
obviously now with uh
you know the old simkin tea is now the
jimmy gt which is pretty cool so
there's a bit of history behind behind
what i do and i just yeah i just really
enjoy that pressure
and you yeah mentioned pressure you've
already mentioned it already that your
clutch kick to win the semi-final for
the canes but throughout your career
you've had so many uh match winning
kicks that you've you've stood up and
nailed so have you have you stayed so
calm under that pressure
yeah i think that the key to to be a
successful goal kicker is
um just trusting your process
and to be able to get into a zone and i
use a lot of visualization like like now
because
yeah in the amount of played i don't
kick a hell of a lot during the week uh
i'll probably kick
maybe twice twice a week and that would
only be you know six seven six kicks or
something a session
i do most of my training at night time
and when i just before i go to bed i
visualize uh right down from putting the
ball on the tee to my run up to what i
do
um i visualize uh the kick do three or
four kicks a night and like for example
if i was playing uh london iris this
week i i know their stadium so i've got
it in my head
and i so can i can picture the the kick
i can picture the stadium
and it just
allows me to when i get to a game just
to be already put the ball on the tee i
look up and i can already see it going
through and it just gives me the
confidence just to
relax and just do my thing and i think
that's really helped me throughout my
career is
that visualization and just really
honing my skill and then just back him
believe in myself
when did you start your visualization
um a bit later on in my career probably
i think it was more um
over here uh
yeah
exactly when i started um
yeah
it was it wasn't like uh
it's something i just learned through um
i think i might have read a golf book or
something like yeah they were talking
about visualization and um how they do
it and so i just sort of started trying
it and it just sort of i was like yeah
this is this is pretty good um
and it just sort of took
you can actually do a lot of reps in
your head than than physically doing
them on the pitch and so that sort of
helped me probably help my body as well
um not banging away 100 kicks a week and
so
yeah i always like you know now i i run
sort of in kicking academy so i'm always
working with younger kids and that's one
thing i tell them you know just to start
visualizing it'll really help you
yeah and speaking of your kicking
academy how did you what made you want
to set this up
i just thought like
talking to
you know parents and and young kids
there's nothing there's nothing like
that over here there's no no one to
teach them
um you know just the fundamentals of
kicking so they can go out there and
just enjoy themselves it's not that
they're going to be a professional
kicker or whatever it's just so they can
get the skill and to be able to go out
on a saturday or sunday whenever they
play and just to be able to do
um the skill to the abyssability
and and to enjoy it um was sort of
the leading factor but
yeah i i really enjoy just seeing the
kids like yeah within 10 minutes you can
change someone's you know
perspective on on how they kick and that
they've got a big smile and and just
enjoying it so it's been pretty cool um
daylight savings has started here so i'm
pretty busy on
trying to fit people in at night i'm
lucky we've got long days over here so
it's good it's good fun
and the jimmy gt's was that off the back
of the kicking academy
no mate so crazy story about that so
obviously everyone knows the simpkin tea
so obviously
mertz used tony brown all these all
these guys used it back in in new
zealand through the time and george
simkin
designed this tea
um
when did he bring it out i can't
remember david it was one of the first
ever kicking tees in the world uh he
brought it out
and you know i david holwell used to use
it he modified it a bit cut it and made
a little bit taller but i had to change
when i went to wellington mate because i
used to kick off a normal cone you know
like just the average cone yeah and i
went down to wellington and the things
just blow off like all the time
because it's so bloody windy so
i've seen yeah i've seen mertz and tony
brown and these guys using the t so
i was like i'll i'll grab that and uh
you know i've used it ever since and
just before i first ever locked down
over here i just got an email a message
on facebook from this guy called george
simkin i was looking at going george
simkin like surely that can't be the
simpkin
just saying look um i've followed your
career i'd love to have a chat with you
give us um here's my number if you if
you want to have a chat come have a chat
i think it will benefit you so i was
quite intrigued like
yeah who who's this george simpson wants
to have a chat so why not have a chat so
anyway give me a ring
and oh what a guy um some of his stories
from rugby he's been
he's done so much in the rugby community
and
he long story short he said look i've
only got a few months to live
and i've always watched your career i
love how you kick
and you're still using my tea
i would love to give you the rights to
use to reproduce my tea
under your name
and i was like really i was like blown
away like blown away by it
and um so i was like right unreal like
tried to get as much information had
loads of conversations with them
but unfortunately he passed away pretty
quickly
um
and sort of into when i first met him
and
and then lockdown really took took uh
hold in the uk and it was really hard to
like for me to try and get things going
with the business and like trying to get
the mold and
um
you know the design and all that kind of
stuff so i never really got it out
before
um
you know he could see it which was
pretty disappointing but
it is it is here now there's a few on my
table so you can see the old jimmy gt
jeez look at that what a design so
yeah but it's like the old sim can see
everyone knows the sim can see it's
the old classic kicking tee it's got the
two levels you can pop it up and
so i've always used this teeth ever like
you know my whole career
um
and for him to say you know
you can reproduce it under your name
because he stopped re stopped producing
in 2010 he said a truck was uh in china
moving it they might have been moving
factories or something and it like
crashed and they lost all the moulds
so he was a bugger of uh i've done this
for so many years so i'm not going to
reproduce them and then here's me over
here when i first came over 2009-2010
season stressing going i can't find any
bloody new tees so i had an old tip top
uh tip top ice cream container that i
had my tees in it
and like i just secure them in there man
like i was looking after them like gold
and it was even like i seen were playing
the newcastle and the ball boy was
sitting there on the it was on the
sideline going like this like bending it
like back and forth and i turned mid mid
game i stopped what i was doing i turned
around i felt bad for the kid
oh
you little [ __ ] like stop doing that
don't bend my teeth because i only had a
few left
so i was like they were like precious
so fortunately now i've got um
you know obviously i sell them now
on
jimmygtz.com and
and i got uh well i had about i've got a
thousand of them in my garage so i'm not
short of a kicking tee at the moment
wait how good is that what a story that
is and is that sort of your plan after
footy to get more into the kicking
coaching and
um selling the jimmy gts
yeah look at something i'm looking at
i'm looking at designing a bit of a
taller t now at the moment
in sort of some similar lines just
because obviously
guys like different heights
but it's something yeah like i enjoy and
i don't know if i come back to new
zealand i don't know how many people are
doing that kind of thing in new zealand
um
you know i'd love to to sort of catch up
with my team and
[ __ ] walk around and you know my sort
of dream job would be cruising around
like taranaki hawke's bay like going all
the provinces is helping with kicking
and
like exit plans and skill work because
you know obviously it's huge over here
so i feel i've learned a lot and
if i can give back some sort of way like
that then it's um
it's really good and enjoyable for me as
well
what about professional coaching
obviously you've been in the game for 19
years playing in a pivotal position
obviously understand the game really
well in all sides of the world
was professional coaching is that
something you'd ever want to get into
yeah look i've been i've been coaching a
local team down here for the last five
years
which is which is pretty cool but i also
do a lot sort of within the younger guys
around the place or sort of with wasp
and stuff but
i think it's a natural progression um
it's kind of everyone tells me i should
be should be doing it but i think it's
just a natural progression and if it
comes my way then yeah the opportunity
comes then obviously i'll look into it
uh
but you know there's there's
loads of sort of things and
opportunities just you know if i move
back to new zealand then you've got to
look into opportunities what
opportunities do i have and you know
i've been playing this game for you know
19 20 years now it's
something that i want to give back and
i've got a lot of knowledge you know
someone once told me uh your knowledge
is not for yourself it's to share and
uh you know i think of i've seen a lot
of a lot of teams
play and been in a lot of environments
and learnt a lot
um hopefully i can give give back and if
that's just
going in and and helping schools or or
clubs or you know whatever then you know
i'm open to all options i love that so
are you looking to uh once once your
career is over in the next five or ten
years are you looking to finish up here
in
new zealand will you is this where you
think you'll live
um look obviously i became a british
citizen uh this year so
which is pretty cool but you know now
life's been here for the last 13 years
but in saying that i've missed all my
family i haven't been around my family
for so long and
i think nanaki is just
an exceptional place to bring kids up
and and for
just your environment you live in and so
i probably see ourselves moving back to
the naki
um at some time stage but and then again
you just don't know because you don't
know what kind of opportunities come up
um after rugby and and things like that
but it's definitely um
something we're looking into
how old are your kids yeah
uh so my daughter will be 14 in july and
the young fella is uh coming up nine
so she's sort of in that niggly age when
yeah
yeah he's a he's a
he's a not bad little rugby player the
little bugger he's uh
he's got some speed it's not from me but
he's doing all right
yeah but my daughter's in that age now
would sort of
if we're gonna move
back to the nike it's probably gonna be
you have to be soon because of her age
or we've got to stay here for a little
bit longer
um but yeah
things will work itself out
no doubt well as always we've gone to
our instagram for some questions
and man lots and lots of questions have
come in for the
uk superstar the hurricane legend and
all the rest first thing was the most
popular question i already sort of
touched on it but all the naki lads all
the locals wanted to know if you're ever
gonna play a game for coastal
oh my i'm deaf i'll definitely play for
the coast even if it's
senior thirds or something i'll have to
have a game
um but yeah no there's there's no doubt
i'll uh i'll have to to come and put on
the put on the strip and and run out for
sure
mate it could be a backline of bowdoin
barrett jimmy gopher geordie barrett
could have the whole crew out there
oh mate let's make it happen eh that'd
be funny that'd be good
be good good crowd good crowd coming to
watch
second most common question was about
this hit from jimmy cowan any memories
from this i don't remember it personally
but you probably do
oh it's
yeah yeah no it's all over youtube that
one few of the boys over here always
tend to uh find that one
um
it was it was decent what made it worse
was like for him
was
i was just going to kick so
like my my plant for of my left foot was
barely on the ground so obviously i've
got no support and he smacks me and then
i just get like full whiplash and i
remember one of the boys
i got i stayed on i got brought off a
little bit after because one of the boys
was like mate you're calling calls that
i've never heard of ever true yeah like
i was just rambling on about some
[ __ ] so
um but that was just because i've got a
bit of whiplash but he got me good mate
he was it was a good hit for sure
was it shoulder to the shoulder to the
head
no
it was more like it was a bit high but
it was more the whiplash i think that
done the because he hit me so hard and
then my sort of just head just bang
straight off the back of the
on the floor
um and that's probably what gave me gave
gave me a bit of a bit of a daze
so were you knocked out
uh i don't know
that was before the hia systems
obviously came in
yeah mate it was way before then so i i
think like it was a it was a
definitely a good sort of uh
a good days for sure like um you know if
i'm calling calls that if the boys had
never heard of
then obviously something went on but it
was more just the whiplash i hit my head
so hard on the back of my back of my
head um it's definitely uh blacked out
for a little bit
but
yeah it's one of those things isn't it
is that something that scares you at all
is uh have you had many concussions
throughout your career obviously i'm
your good mate at newcastle carl
heyman's come out with um some sad news
about his dementia but have you felt
like you've got any um issues with your
head you sound like you've got a good
memory
yeah i
i have never really had one uh never
really had um like a proper a knockout
um i got sort of
the season's been a funny one like i got
pre-season just training uh caught a
knee to the head
and just sort of got a bit staggering
and
[Music]
and sort of just went off
on the sideline i was like look i i just
need a re i need a minute
and i could just tell i was like i'm
just a bit dizzy here anyway they they i
tried to keep it quiet as
as some of us do but um
they they got me and had to do an hoa
and i failed
but
and then
it was probably about four weeks later
uh
big mike williams who plays for bath
i was on the jackal and he just lined me
up from miles out man and uh next minute
i woke up and i had oxygen mask on
um
that was the first time i've ever been
proper knocked out and
yeah i just remember
waking up oxygen mask on people all
around me
and then just saying to the trainer i
was like well the physio i was like i've
been knocked out haven't i and he was
like yep and he was like you were
snoring uh it was a proper like
like the old starfish man i was gone
yeah um and then they brought the
stretcher out and i was like nah like
oh
can i stand up like i'm i'm not kidding
i'm not going off in a stretcher
stood up and just
went straight back down and i was like
yeah give me that stretcher i'm dust
and then sat
sat for the rest of the game in the back
of the ambulance
uh and was alright and then sort of
you go through a protocol so you got
five day turnaround so you do all the
the protocol the hia protocol
and like i passed my first day and
with all the words and the memory and
stuff my balance was a little off
so obviously you keep going through the
stages
and there was a it was a pretty big game
coming up and like me being stubborn and
not not wanting to miss a game ever
i was like
i sort of
in in my words i probably just was a bit
like wasn't as truthful as i should have
been and and sort of how i was feeling
because i was at home and i was just i
said to my wishes i was like
i feel like [ __ ] like
um my head just feels
a bit [ __ ] i can't really concentrate
but i kept passing all the tests
like they were doing with me like little
go for a little run
you cycle everything like building up
they build you up nicely but because i
wasn't as honest as i should have been
with uh
sort of how i was actually feeling like
obviously they didn't know because i was
passing on my tests and it got to the
last day where it was like right you
passed your contact
you hit a few bags and grit into your
contact and then you're good to go for
the weekend
and fortunately the coach said to me
straight up to me and goes mate
even if you pass i'm not gonna pick you
like that was a pretty bad knockout i'm
not gonna pick you so yeah don't push if
you don't want to and as soon as he said
that i was like yeah i'm out i'm i'm
done i'm not doing contact like no way
like i'm not doing it like i feel [ __ ]
and it wasn't until the next week
when
i actually started feeling good i was
like [ __ ] i was actually feeling pretty
[ __ ]
but
has just been an old-school
you know rugby player that thinks uh you
know i'll be all right um yeah which was
just stupid like now
you know i always tell the young kids
like
even a few guys have been ko'd this year
i was like mate just take it easy and be
honest
yeah because you've only got one head
and you can't muck around with it and
but yeah that was the first time
i've been proper proper knocked out and
it's pretty scary mate this sounds like
a brutal knockout how long did it take
for you to start feeling good was it
still only two weeks before you're back
out there feeling good
yeah so i was fortunate as in we had the
i think we were playing quinn's the end
of the week at home then we had a week
off
um so i had a good two weeks
probably two and a half weeks to
to sort of get myself set and ready to
go
so it was a good two and a half weeks
and it probably was only the last week
when i started feeling well half a week
really yeah
so a good two weeks
to to make me sort of start feeling
pretty good
right crazy
next question okay best player you've
played with or against there man you
would have played with plenty
yeah i've been asked this question so
many times and you just can't i can't
have an answer like yeah
it's just i've been so fortunate to play
with some of the best players in new
zealand
obviously you've got tana you've got
kali you've got ma conrad and then
leinster briana driscoll et cetera et
cetera so
um
you know and then even at wasp you're
playing with guys like christian wade
and willie leroux curtly beal
like there's just too many too many good
players i'm probably name dropping out
my ass right now but
you know i've been very very
i've been very fortunate to be in some
unbelievable teams and and learned so
much of so many good players
mate you have played with some legends
eh
to play against again you get to play
against all those guys
um probably the the guy that i hated
playing against um
probably bucky's pointer
i got cleaned out by him a couple times
him and sculptberger i honestly like
been a 10 they just come after you i've
been hit a couple times and you knew
you'd been hit
some big boys
oh i like that okay next question is
from orland's major sponsor swish if you
could get a video shout out from any
person in the world who would it be and
why
oh awesome i think kelly slater um
obviously 11 time world champion surfer
um 50 years old still just absolutely
killing it
um
that's the some of his other some of my
mates are
his good mate um one of the pro surfers
i used to know and he just said he's
pretty sound dude and
um yeah i just think he's one of those
you know what other professional athlete
in the world is 11 time world champ
um there's not many you know even tom
brady's and not 11 time world champ it's
uh
he's a pretty phenomenal athlete and
still absolutely killing it in the surf
at the moment 50 years old crazy like
that one that goes on to the next
question about surfing how many
surfboards have you owned
have i owned oh i think i've got about
seven in the garage at the moment
but i live
i live in the midlands mate so i don't
get to surf that often
um it's always just surf trips and
and things it's slowed up a little bit
living in newcastle living in ireland
was phenomenal surfing all the time yeah
but yeah living in the midlands
geographically the middle of england as
far as ways you can get to the ocean
it takes me two hours 40 for the nearest
star surf
true just visualization in the garage on
your surfboards is it
that's the one way i got a lot of a lot
of cobwebs a lot of dust
okay next one's also about surfing best
ways in taranaki or best waves in france
where is it
uh
taranaki for
variation
and i've been a couple times in france
it's just a lot of beaches like
really really good but in the naki mate
you've got everything beaches point
breaks there's a couple secret slabs
around the place
big wave small waves
it's just a it's it's a dream for a
surfer
to have a coastline like that
have you been to any awesome surf spots
since you've been over there obviously
europe's just on your doorstep and lots
of cool places to travel to any
favorites
portugal is pretty fun um had quite a
few surf trips in portugal uh that was
you know there's some awesome surf spots
up there uh one of the weirdest ones
mate is like a place called thurso it's
in scotland it is literally when you
look at uh great britain it's as far as
you can go north low
i live when i lived in newcastle it's
still a nine hour drive from newcastle
sure and you go up there mate and it's
like
literally probably the most inbred place
you'll ever meet ever ever go
it's so barren there's nothing around
and just these amazing waves um so when
i done a surf trap surf trip up there
and actually went up with carl heyman as
well so we used to go up there for a bit
surf trips and yeah it's a pretty
special place
true that sounds cool it must be
freezing was it
weirdly it's cold outside but um like
the north sea down in newcastle is way
colder than up top because it's
sort of the currents that push it push
over the top from uh the different sort
of seas so it was it was cold like it's
still
freezing like um you know but newcastle
will be like four or five degrees and up
there would be like nine nine sort of
eight nine
still cold slightly less freezing
okay next one tell us about your dive
try over the rock
oh
that was against
tonga
i was nearly the most stupid person ever
to do that because against the tongan
boys
if one of them stood up he would have
cut me in half like i just remember the
ball we're playing for the junior all
blacks was that it was actually it uh at
the um
what do they call it now it was a bull
ring so i don't know what they call it
now taranaki uh stadium but um yeah the
yeah
the arrow stadium the ball popped out of
the rock and we're sort of five mil
right on the line
and it popped out um and sort of i can't
i can't remember who who passed me the
ball but they started running across the
pitch so i just sort of ducked under
they gave me the ball
i just
cut back in and then just seen the rock
and thought why not have a go and just
jumped and dove over the top and luckily
no one stood up
and managed to score
because yeah as i said if someone stood
up man i would have got ended
like nearly left
wrong a lot
yeah especially if nilly was there
nearly hitting hit hard and nearly
probably i think he was playing he would
have smoked me
he's another one who's still going too
eh
oh he's a legend
mate okay next question why do they call
you spongebob
uh it's the old square shoulders mate
so spongebob's just built
built like that
uh
it happened a while back i can't
remember exactly who started it but
soon as soon as i got to um to newcastle
the owner gave me a bloody spongebob um
little doll thing so they all knew
it was a cool called spongebob but some
of the wellington boys just end up
calling me spongebob and uh it just
stuck really stuck
but it's gone now massive shoulders but
hopefully it's not coming back
yeah that's the one
okay next one this will be an
interesting one ask him about his battle
with luke mcallister on new zealand
schools tour most hookups
[Laughter]
i used to call him peebs
he's like pretty boy i always used to do
his hair and uh you know i was a
i was from the coast mate i was a farm
boy never even heard of like
gel like hair gel mate and uh
so he was all like this has a nice curly
hair and so i'd always just call him
peebs and so yeah no there was um it was
a pretty pretty special uh tour
uh he tried to like design like
tell me to use all the gel and
uh that was pretty fun mate we're um
we've done a bit of damage around there
and uh and really enjoyed ourselves
who won it
oh mate of course he's going to win it
isn't he
because i just like i'm a coastal admit
as soon as we go into a bar i'll just go
to i'll go to the bar and sit at the bar
he'll be on the dance floor probably and
i'm just sitting there having a few
scoonies
[Laughter]
oh good stuff okay next one who's one
new zealand player who you'd think would
make a great transition into the uk game
um
i think uh
just a few let's look at the canes guys
i think adi would arty savior i think
people would get excited by how he goes
like we've got obviously via for theta
in our team and
i just see like that they're quite
similar in in the way they sort of
play and
their sort of athletic ability and
you know when when via gets
in in open spaces defense just don't
know how to deal with them because he's
running around with the ball in one hand
and he's quick so i think arty would be
he'd sort of excel up here um and
defenses would wouldn't know how to deal
with them really i think he'd do really
well
i think he could play well anywhere to
be fears and he's he's that good yeah
true but you do that you do have an
awesome um you do have an awesome keynes
contingent there at wasp too don't you
you've got shields evaya jeff tumonga
allen you've got all the boys there how
they all been going
yeah good mate yeah it's really nice to
have um
you know some
some guys from from the same club used
to play out even though these boys used
to go and watch me sitting in the stand
and watch me play with their young kids
they always give me [ __ ] about that but
um yeah it's good just to share some
stories and
uh obviously have close to home um you
know sort of comforts there as well it's
pretty cool and
um
you know we we always get together and
have a few beers and and really enjoy
ourselves was pretty good
no doubt shields is leading you astray
always mate he's a bad man
he loves his beer
he loves his socials he's got a company
over here as well so it's uh social they
call it him and josh bassett so they're
doing like vodka and um and all that
kind of stuff it's uh
little sort of rtd drinks they're doing
really well so
there's always having a few of them
after the games which is pretty cool
that's awesome okay last question
best piece of advice you've received in
your 19-year footy career
oh
yeah probably
it's that's a tough one isn't it um
obviously even i said earlier on about
with tana just telling me you know it
doesn't care who you are and just get in
and boss us but you know it's when
someone said just enjoy every moment
you've got because
you never know when this game can finish
and so you gotta respect it and cherish
it because one day drop of a hat
you've lost it so
i think that's been the sort of most
important thing i take every day is just
just enjoy every single moment you've
got because you're very privileged uh to
be in this situation
mate love it what a way to finish i knew
19 years would come into one unreal
piece of advice love that
cheers mate
but mate really appreciate you being
coming on the podcast like i said at the
start massive fan of yours when you when
i was growing up uh leading that cane
site around and then um to see you still
go on and do what you've done over in
the uk and i'm still playing at the
level you are and plenty more years left
to go mate it's been pretty
inspirational to watch and i've been
awesome having you on and sharing
sharing your journey
uh cheers for having me on mate it's
always good to have a yarn and uh
you know it's good to see what you're
doing here with what a lad so uh big ups
to you and no doubt we'll uh catch up
when we're home have a beer or two
no doubt you're a lad appreciate it mate
[Music]
[Music]